Yeah, I got to go back and grab something from the pilot because I realized after we finished taping that one of my favorite lines and moments in the pilot that Ted got to say, I forgot to mention and it's when he's talking to Yasmeen and he says, it's not like a sit-around all day fantasizing about my wedding and then he goes into this whole very specific fantasy about his wedding, which he ends with, bam, no DJ, people will dance, I'm not going to worry about it, right?
是的，我得回去从试播集里拿点东西，因为我意识到，在我们录制完试播集里我最喜欢的台词和时刻之一，特德说，我忘了提，就在他和亚斯明说话的时候，他说，这不像是整天坐着幻想我的婚礼，然后他进入了关于他的婚礼的整个非常具体的幻想，最后他结束了，砰，没有 DJ，人们会跳舞，我不会担心它，对吗？
And I loved the phrase people will dance.
我喜欢人们会跳舞这句话。
Like as a notion of like, I'm not going to worry about it.
就像作为一个“喜欢”的概念一样，我不会担心它。
It became shorthand in my life.
它成了我生活中的速记。
The woman that I was seeing when I got how I met your mother who worked on the audition sides with me.
当我知道我是如何认识你母亲时我所见到的那个女人，她和我一起在试镜方面工作。
She was Eastern European and she found that also so charming.
她是东欧人，她发现这也很迷人。
And our mantra was, and she would say it in this accent that was adorable to me.
我们的口头禅是，她会用我喜欢的口音说出来。
People would dance.
人们会跳舞。
I'm not going to worry about it.
我不会为此担心。
Like it'll take care of itself.
就像它会照顾自己一样。
And I named my corporation people will dance.
我命名我的公司“人们会跳舞”。
Like it really became this mantra of, remember what I said?
就像它真的成为了这句口头禅，还记得我说的话吗？
All people want to be told is it's going to be okay.
所有人都希望被告知一切都会好起来的。
Yes.
是的。
For me, the phrase people will dance is that it's still that in my head.
对我来说，人们会跳舞这句话现在仍然在我的脑海里。
Like people will dance.
就像人们会跳舞一样。
Like people are going to have a good time.
就像人们会度过愉快的时光一样。
You don't have to micromanage every last bit of life or this evening or whatever.
你不必对生活的最后一点、今晚的事或其他什么事情进行微观管理。
So that, to me, I suppose if I was getting a phrase from how I met her with her tattooed, I don't have any tattoos, but people from the world all over the world get to, how I met your mother tattoos.
所以，对我来说，我想如果我从我如何遇见她和她的纹身中得到一句话，我没有任何纹身，但来自世界各地的人们都会得到，我如何遇见你母亲的纹身。
I've seen a lot of how I met your mother tattoos.
我见过很多关于我如何遇见你母亲的纹身。
If I were getting one, it would probably be people will dance.
如果我得到一个，那可能是人们会跳舞。
Hey, welcome to a very special bonus episode of how we made your mother.
嘿，欢迎收看关于我们如何造就你母亲的非常特别的奖励剧集。
This is an episode we call General Questions.
这是我们称之为“一般问题”的一集。
General Questions.
一般问题。
I'm Josh Radder.
我是乔什·雷德。
I am here with, who am I here with?
我和谁在这里？
You hear what's Craig Thomas?
你听到克雷格·托马斯是什么了吗？
Craig Thomas, the co-creator of how I met your mother and our friend, Alec Lev, and we're going to burn through some reader mail, harkening back to Carter and Craig's origins of doing the letterman reader mail.
克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）是《我如何遇见你母亲》和我们的朋友亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）的共同创作者，我们将浏览一些读者邮件，回顾一下卡特和克雷格处理莱特曼读者邮件的起源。
We should back it up for a second.
我们应该支持一下。
I'll read and say that the running joke on how much weather doesn't start till season two, but whenever anybody says, I have a general question or I have a major problem, everyone And so it's in such a general question, major problem, that's general questions.
我会读到并说关于天气的笑话直到第二季才开始，但每当有人说，我有一个一般性问题或我有一个主要问题，每个人，所以这是一个一般性问题，主要问题，这是一般性问题。
Yeah, that is the, and this is my, my proudest, my proudest moment in life was when I turned on the TV one Monday night, and there was this stupid, saluting thing that I know it everyone with in college, but they all picked it up, Craig, so we work and I went to college to go to a living on in college.
是的，这就是我，我一生中最自豪的时刻，就是当我周一晚上打开电视时，我看到了大学里每个人都知道的愚蠢的、致敬的事情，但他们都接受了它，克雷格，所以我们工作，我上了大学，在大学里谋生。
He brainwashed me into doing this.
他给我洗脑让我这么做。
There is something sticky social contagion about the joke.
这个笑话具有某种粘性的社会感染力。
For some reason, even if you've grown the first time you hear it, once you get it in your head, so it's major general and what else?
出于某种原因，即使你第一次听到它时就长大了，一旦你把它记在你的脑海里，那么它就是少将，还有什么？
Oh, private.
哦，私人的。
You can have a private conversation.
您可以进行私人对话。
Private conversation.
私人谈话。
Yeah.
是的。
You can, but you could take it.
你可以，但你可以接受。
You could take it very far.
你可以走得很远。
We'll get into that as we don't want to give it all the way right here, but yes, there's a season two bit on the show.
我们会深入讨论这个问题，因为我们不想在这里把它全部讲完，但是是的，这部剧还有第二季。
Alec, did I ask you permission to steal this bill?
亚历克，我有没有征得你的同意来偷这张钞票？
There was this one of the many, many times.
这一次是无数次中的一次。
I just stole things like I'm like a fucking dick.
我只是偷东西，就像我像个混蛋一样。
No, but this this was truly the proudest and I will say that was it a surprise to be honest was it a surprise?
不，但这确实是最值得骄傲的，我会说，说实话，这是一个惊喜吗？
I'm thinking it was just that I never really was I guess I probably chose to surprise you because I knew you would like it I will say that I have a very good friend who told me that she used to do this with her friend You know 10 years ago 15 years ago from the show dude all the time I was like that's all coming in a circle But speaking of bringing a circle and I'm just happy you're finally gonna get credit for this, Alex.
我想这只是我从来没有真正是我想我可能选择给你一个惊喜，因为我知道你会喜欢它我会说我有一个非常好的朋友告诉我她曾经和她的朋友这样做你知道10年前15年前从节目中一直以来我都觉得这一切都是一个圆圈但是说到带来一个圆圈，我很高兴你终于能因此而获得荣誉，亚历克斯。
This is something.
这是一些东西。
This has been a long time coming.
这已经是很长一段时间了。
All like, this is why I'm doing this podcast, my friends.
朋友们，这就是我做这个播客的原因。
But to show how long a tale and amazing a story this is, Josh, you got an incredible letter.
但为了表明这是一个多么长的故事和一个多么令人惊奇的故事，乔什，你收到了一封令人难以置信的信。
I got, I got an unbelievable note.
我得到了，我得到了一张令人难以置信的纸条。
I won't say their names unless they, they authorize it because they didn't really write this for us to share the podcast, but it's so incredible.
我不会说出他们的名字，除非他们授权，因为他们写这篇文章并不是为了我们分享播客，但这太不可思议了。
We have to share it.
我们必须分享它。
And fitting with me, stealing it from Alex, we're just going to steal this kind of viewers.
和我一样，从亚历克斯那里偷来的，我们只是要偷走这种观众。
This is from a couple who said, this is the husband writing me, that his wife was 38 weeks pregnant with their daughter.
这是一对夫妇说的，这是丈夫写信给我的，他的妻子怀着他们的女儿已经怀孕 38 周了。
And the wife had had several days of early labor and pain before they finally admitted her to the hospital.
在他们最终将妻子送进医院之前，她已经经历了几天的早产和疼痛。
And then she had over 30 hours of labor in the hospital, which you guys have had wives who've given birth.
然后她在医院里待了30多个小时，你们这些人都已经生过孩子了。
That's a long time, right?
那是很长一段时间了，对吧？
That's a long run, man.
这是一个漫长的过程，伙计。
That's 30 hours of labor with her last pushes.
算上最后一次用力，这已经是 30 个小时的分娩时间了。
The nurse said, push, you're having a major contraction and through all the pain and pushing, my wife looks at me and salutes to major contraction.
护士说，用力，你正在经历剧烈宫缩，在所有的疼痛和用力中，我的妻子看着我，向剧烈宫缩致敬。
It's just the best.
这只是最好的。
It's just the best story.
这只是最好的故事。
It's an unbelievable story.
这是一个令人难以置信的故事。
That's so good.
那太好了。
It's so good.
太好了。
So, we thank you to the mighty marvelous couple out there who did a how I met your mother inside joke at the moment of pushing a baby out.
所以，我们要感谢那对伟大的奇妙夫妇，他们在推出婴儿的那一刻做了一个我如何认识你母亲的内部笑话。
And it's our joke is the baby came out, I mean, what a major contraction, I mean, major respect to this amazing woman and to whatever lucky gentleman got to marry her and have a child with her.
这是我们的笑话，孩子出生了，我的意思是，这是一个多么大的宫缩，我的意思是，对这位了不起的女人以及与她结婚并生下孩子的幸运绅士表示极大的敬意。
That's unbelievable.
这太难以置信了。
That's how you know this.
你就是这样知道的。
Did you ever know?
你知道吗？
That's how you know this marriage is going to last.
这就是你知道这段婚姻会持续下去的方式。
I mean, it's really, I have no doubt about that marriage and Alec could, did high school you that began this joke that presumably everyone hated you for?
我的意思是，我真的对这段婚姻毫不怀疑，亚历克可以，高中时你就开始了这个可能每个人都讨厌你的笑话吗？
Sure.
当然。
of imagined this, this would boomerang back around to us.
想象一下，这会飞去来器回到我们身边。
And like that, this could possibly is this a, this a blow your mind.
就这样，这可能是这，这让你大吃一惊。
No, that was the point.
不，这就是重点。
That was the point.
这就是重点。
The whole time.
整个时间。
You played a long game.
你打了一场漫长的比赛。
The world.
世界。
And this is the long, the long, the long.
这是很长，很长，很长。
And it was college.
那是大学。
I held off until I met you.
我一直拖延直到遇见你。
I didn't annoy them in high school.
我高中时没有惹恼过他们。
Yeah.
是的。
I thought it was cool to bust it out freshman here in college.
我觉得在大学一年级就能够解决这个问题很酷。
All right.
好的。
So, you know, we're, we've We only announced a show, a little time-ending here.
所以，你知道，我们，我们只是宣布了一场演出，在这里有点时间结束。
We announced the show in our lives, not that long ago, and have been flooded not only with stories, but also literally a minute before we recorded our episode about the pilot.
不久前，我们在生活中宣布了这部剧，不仅充满了故事，而且在我们录制有关试播集的剧集前一分钟也充满了故事。
I went on to Instagram and I said, hey, does anyone have any questions?
我去了 Instagram，我说，嘿，有人有任何问题吗？
And by the time the hour was done of recording, I had 350 of them, and I got to precisely almost zero because Josh and Craig just had so much to say about the pilot.
当一小时的录音结束时，我已经录制了 350 首，而我的录制几乎为零，因为乔什和克雷格对试播集有太多话要说。
So we thought we'd hold it off and just do a rapid fire, get some of the fan questions out here.
所以我们认为我们应该推迟并快速进行，在这里回答一些粉丝的问题。
Some of these you will have answered before.
其中一些您之前已经回答过。
And a lot of these are one question represents 10 questions that were of the same topic.
其中很多是一个问题代表同一主题的 10 个问题。
So let's just dive in.
那么让我们来深入了解一下吧。
So Alice, 2388 asks, Josh, how much do you relate to Ted in real life?
所以爱丽丝，2388 问，乔什，你和现实生活中的泰德有多少关系？
I'll say that's a big question.
我会说这是一个大问题。
That's what we're going to be talking about through the whole series.
这就是我们将在整个系列中讨论的内容。
So I'm going to bend it a little bit if that's okay.
所以如果可以的话我会把它弯曲一点。
In our last episode, you said you sort of gave grace to your younger Josh Self.
在我们的上一集中，你说你给了年轻的乔什·塞尔夫以恩典。
You had some advice for your younger Josh Self who was feeling certain things.
你给年轻的乔什·塞尔夫（Josh Self）一些建议，因为他对某些事情有感觉。
What would older Ted have to say to younger Ted in the pilot?
在试播集中，年长的泰德会对年轻的泰德说些什么？
He's a, he was a very intense guy.
他是一个非常热情的人。
Yeah.
是的。
What, what can you give him?
什么，你能给他什么？
Well, I, I mean, it's more like, I mean, acting is so strange.
嗯，我，我的意思是，这更像是，我的意思是，表演是如此奇怪。
I, I always, um, think about what my acting teacher did and why you said Ron Bandleau.
我，我总是，嗯，思考我的表演老师做了什么，以及为什么你说罗恩·班德洛。
he said, a character is a 50% meeting of you and the character.
他说，一个角色就是你和这个角色50%的相遇。
So I lend 50% of the kind of DNA and the character, as Crack and Carter wrote, wrote the character is also that other 50%.
所以我借出了 50% 的 DNA 和角色，正如 Crack 和 Carter 所写，所写的角色也是另外 50%。
So you're kind of like meeting this other thing to form this thing that looks like a dimensional real person.
所以你有点像遇到了另一个东西，形成了这个看起来像一个维度真人的东西。
So I'm loathed to kind of act like 10.
所以我讨厌表现得像10号一样。
I don't know when people say like, oh, do it like 10.
我不知道什么时候人们会说，哦，像 10 那样做吧。
I'm like, I don't know.
我想，我不知道。
looked at us to do things in character.
看着我们做事的性格。
I'm like, I don't know what you mean, like without the words from the script, like there is nothing, there's no character, but I am underneath the skin of him where I was for a long time.
我想，我不知道你的意思，就像没有剧本中的台词一样，就像什么都没有，没有角色，但我很长一段时间都在他的皮肤下面。
I think, you know, if my younger self had told a woman that he was wildly attracted to that he loved her on the first date and kind of blew it.
我想，你知道，如果年轻时的我告诉一个女人，他在第一次约会时就被她深深吸引，他爱她，然后就搞砸了。
And I knew what I know now, I would say, you know, Humiliation is part of life like it's a it's a it's almost like initiatory like you get humiliated and I was listening to this guy Scott Galoway who's a really interesting thinker and he's he's talking about men the kind of crisis of Manhood and he said when men are just on their screens alone.
我知道我现在所知道的，我会说，你知道，羞辱是生活的一部分，就像它几乎就像你受到羞辱一样，我正在听斯科特·加洛韦这个人的讲话，他是一位非常有趣的思想家，他正在谈论男人的那种男子气概危机，他说当男人独自在屏幕上时。
They don't know how to take big swings out in the world They they need to go out and and learn to be humiliated now.
他们不知道如何在世界上做出巨大的改变，他们现在需要走出去，学会被羞辱。
I learned to be humiliated honestly somewhat by women, but not as much.
我学会了诚实地受到女性的羞辱，但没有那么严重。
Here's what taught me humiliation was being a young actor.
这就是作为一名年轻演员让我感受到的羞辱。
Going in, roll after roll, sometimes nailing it, not getting the job, sometimes getting the job, sometimes blowing it, you know, being unprepared or just getting too nervous.
进去后，一卷接着一卷，有时成功了，但没有得到这份工作，有时得到了工作，有时却搞砸了，你知道，因为没有准备好或者只是太紧张了。
Like, I really had to learn how to be humiliated and pick myself back up and keep going.
就像，我真的必须学会如何受到羞辱并振作起来并继续前进。
And I think it's one of the great qualities of Ted, which I hope I share, Is this ability to get knocked down?
我认为这是特德的伟大品质之一，我希望我能分享这一点，这是被击倒的能力吗？
And he sometimes literally, like he got punched a lot in the show, like he sometimes literally gets punched down, and he gets back up.
他有时真的，就像他在节目中被打了很多拳，就像他有时真的被打倒了，然后他又站了起来。
So I think it's more like, if someone's, you know, if a younger person says, I got humiliated as an older mentor figure, I think you say, good, yeah, this is what you need, you need to be humiliated.
所以我认为这更像是，如果有人，你知道，如果一个年轻人说，我作为一个年长的导师人物而受到羞辱，我想你会说，好，是的，这就是你需要的，你需要被羞辱。
You need to take swings, you need to put yourself out there and you need to get somewhat, You get need to get a thicker skin, you get need to get immune to the kind of criticism and humiliation and just keep going.
你需要采取行动，你需要把自己放在那里，你需要得到一些，你需要变得更厚的脸皮，你需要免受批评和羞辱，然后继续前进。
So I would just tell them to pick himself up and it's all going to be all right.
所以我只会告诉他们振作起来，一切都会好起来的。
Ultimately, I think all anyone wants to hear is it's going to be okay.
最终，我想每个人都想听到的是一切都会好起来的。
Yes.
是的。
Like that's all anyone wants to hear ever.
就像这就是任何人都想听到的那样。
Yeah.
是的。
It's the most evergreen piece of like pep talk advice you could give.
这是你能提供的最常青的鼓舞人心的建议。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
You have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that caused that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会解决它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
Craig, the Dodger Munch asks a question you must have gotten a lot back in the day, but let's cover it officially now.
克雷格，道奇蒙克问了一个问题，你今天肯定已经得到了很多，但现在让我们正式讨论它。
Why did you cast Bob Sagitt as the old Ted, which we could split that into two questions.
你为什么让鲍勃·萨吉特扮演老泰德，我们可以把它分成两个问题。
Why was there an old Ted period and why Bob Sagitt?
为什么会有一个旧的泰德时期，为什么会有鲍勃·萨吉特？
Yeah, great.
是的，太棒了。
The great Bob Saga.
伟大的鲍勃传奇。
By the way, let's yeah, the great Bob Saga.
顺便说一句，是的，伟大的鲍勃传奇。
And we will, we will get to the episode where we do a whole episode is about how much we love Bob Saga and how much we miss Bob Saga and how lucky we were to work with him.
我们将会，我们将进入这一集，我们会用一整集来讲述我们有多么爱鲍勃·萨加，我们有多么想念鲍勃·萨加，以及我们有多么幸运能与他合作。
I'm so glad that we did it.
我很高兴我们做到了。
I will say that when we were first writing it, we thought the actor who played Ted would do the voiceover.
我要说的是，当我们第一次写它时，我们认为扮演泰德的演员会做画外音。
And in fact, I don't believe it was our idea to have an older person.
事实上，我不认为我们有一个老年人的想法。
do the role.
扮演这个角色。
I think CBS, an older scheming network at the time, we were the youngest show on that network for all nine years that we were on that network, I believe, I think that's true.
我认为哥伦比亚广播公司，当时是一个较老的阴谋网络，我们是该网络九年来最年轻的节目，我相信，我认为这是真的。
I think the executives there said, because I think we talked, we had the idea, we considered a different actor doing that voice, but I think we were leaning more towards Josh would do it.
我认为那里的高管说，因为我认为我们谈过，我们有这个想法，我们考虑过由不同的演员来制作这个声音，但我认为我们更倾向于乔什会这样做。
And I think I have to give credit to CBS and the studio for saying like, there will be something here on CBS to having a trusted voice of an actor in his 50s, who we've all grown up with, America's funny, some videos, full house, he feels like your dad, he feels like this trusted part, he's been in your living room before and it will help the viewers that are watching CBS feel connected to the show in a way that maybe they wouldn't.
我想我必须赞扬 CBS 和工作室的说法，CBS 会有一个 50 多岁的演员值得信赖的声音，我们都和他一起长大，美国很有趣，一些视频，满座，他感觉就像你的父亲，他感觉像这个值得信赖的部分，他以前来过你的客厅，这将帮助观看 CBS 的观众以一种他们可能不会的方式感受到与节目的联系。
But that was sort of the practical part, the creative part, and I think this was more important, was this idea that future U is kind of a different guy, right?
但这是实用的部分，创造性的部分，我认为这更重要，未来的U是一个不同的人，对吗？
The guy, the Ted in 2005 and the Ted in 2030, they're different people, just like Josh and I are different people from 2005 and now, and having Bob do that role, he brought this kind of wisdom and warmth and to go back to Josh's question, ability to look back on having been humiliated with wit, humor, acceptance, grace, like he had that in his voice, he was a stand-up comedian Bob Sagit.
这个人，2005 年的泰德和 2030 年的泰德，他们是不同的人，就像乔什和我从 2005 年到现在都是不同的人一样，让鲍勃扮演这个角色，他带来了这种智慧和温暖，回到乔什的问题，有能力以机智、幽默、接受、优雅的方式回顾被羞辱的经历，就像他的声音一样，他是一个单口喜剧演员鲍勃·萨吉特。
He went up and bombed in front of audiences.
他站起来，在观众面前轰炸。
He killed in front of audiences.
他在观众面前杀人。
You hear all his history in his voice.
你可以从他的声音中听到他所有的历史。
He's a fantastic actor too.
他也是一位出色的演员。
He took the role really seriously.
他非常认真地对待这个角色。
He really loved Josh.
他真的很爱乔希。
He tried to get to know Josh and connect with Josh.
他试图了解乔什并与乔什建立联系。
So he was future Ted.
所以他就是未来的特德。
He would come hang out on the set.
他会来片场闲逛。
He didn't have to do that when he'd come to voiceovers.
当他来配音时，他不必这样做。
He'd come say hi because he wanted to feel what the show was and that sort of connection between these two Ted's but who were the same guy, but we're different guys, the way we all are.
他会来打招呼，因为他想感受一下这个节目是什么，以及这两个 Ted 之间的联系，但我们是同一个人，但我们是不同的人，我们都是这样的。
And 30, 25 years apart, I think it became such an asset to the show.
相隔 30 年、25 年，我认为这对这部剧来说是一笔宝贵的财富。
And I can't claim credit for it.
我不能把这归功于它。
In fact, we may have had to be, I think we got convinced of it through the process.
事实上，我们可能不得不这样做，我想我们在这个过程中已经确信了这一点。
And we were willing to be resistant.
我们愿意抵抗。
You know, I had a couple moments where I was like, man, I wish I was doing the voice, but I love, I ended up loving Bob so much that I was so happy that there was this introduction and that we got to be friends all these years.
你知道，有几次我想，伙计，我希望我能配音，但我爱，我最终非常爱鲍勃，所以我很高兴有这个介绍，而且这些年来我们成为了朋友。
But also it was fun to watch Bob.
但观看鲍勃的表演也很有趣。
He became a fan of the show huge because he would watch it in the sound booth and he loved the show.
他成为了这部剧的忠实粉丝，因为他会在录音室里观看这部剧，而且他很喜欢这部剧。
He was really he loved it.
他真的很喜欢它。
And yeah, I ultimately I ultimately think it was it was the right move and I'm so I'm so glad that I that I knew him.
是的，我最终认为这是正确的举动，我很高兴我认识他。
And also, you know, he and I had some real deep talks about being overly associated with a show, because he had that with full house.
而且，你知道，他和我就与演出过度相关进行了一些真正深入的讨论，因为他在满座的时候就这样了。
Yeah.
是的。
So he offered me some real wisdom and more than anything, just the wisdom to keep going.
所以他给了我一些真正的智慧，最重要的是，就是继续前进的智慧。
No, but I mean, thinking about Bob, Bob was a genius at complicating and diversifying his image past full house.
不，但我的意思是，想想鲍勃，鲍勃是一个天才，他善于将自己的形象复杂化和多样化，超越满堂彩。
He really appreciated it.
他真的很感激。
Like, I'm going to show you some other moves.
就像，我将向您展示一些其他动作。
I'm going to show you some other, which I was more really comfortable on my own skin.
我将向您展示其他一些，我个人感觉更舒服。
I wish I was more comfortable working blue.
我希望我在蓝色工作时能更舒服。
That's not my thing.
那不是我的事。
But it only worked with him because you knew he was a wrench.
但这只对他有用，因为你知道他是个扳手。
You knew he was all heart underneath it.
你知道他的内心是全心全意的。
It came across and there was a perpetual wink in it.
它碰到了，里面不停地眨着眼睛。
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对是。
That's how it was fun.
就是这样才有趣。
No, no, no, no.
不，不，不，不。
Zero, no, zero, no, zero, no.
零，不，零，不，零，不。
I love.
我爱。
Yeah.
是的。
Dr. Marie 15 again has a big question.
玛丽博士15又提出了一个大问题。
But Josh, can you think of a time in that during the pilot.
但是乔什，你能想到试播期间的某个时刻吗？
In those early days, weeks when you felt like, oh, this group is clicking this cast.
在最初的几天、几周里，当你感觉，哦，这个团队正在点击这个演员阵容。
Well, you know, Neil and I had done a play together, like a really intense John Robin Bates play like months before.
嗯，你知道，尼尔和我一起演过一场戏，就像几个月前约翰·罗宾·贝茨 (John Robin Bates) 演的一场非常激烈的戏。
So I knew we worked well together.
所以我知道我们合作得很好。
I mean, I think it was pretty immediate.
我的意思是，我认为这是非常直接的。
I knew from the testing audition situation that Kobe and I, you know, had a real fizz together.
从试镜的情况来看，我知道科比和我在一起玩得很开心。
And then when we got the whole gang together, I remember, I remember writers telling me that they all recognized that when the five of us were around that table was when the show felt so alive to them.
然后，当我们把整个团伙聚集在一起时，我记得，我记得作家们告诉我，他们都认识到，当我们五个人围坐在那张桌子旁时，这部剧对他们来说就显得如此生动。
So they were, in Craig, you can back me up on this but like trying to write more for the five, you know, the five, the gang of five, I think it was, I remember the champagne night and maybe it was just because I was a little buzzed, but I definitely felt like we He made something really great and I have a quiet, good feeling about this because I had had everything happen to me in the world of making television pilots except getting a hit show.
所以他们，在克雷格，你可以支持我，但就像试图为五个人写更多，你知道，五个人，五个人的帮派，我想是的，我记得香槟之夜，也许只是因为我有点兴奋，但我确实觉得我们他做了一些非常伟大的事情，我对此有一种安静的、良好的感觉，因为在制作电视试播集的世界里，除了获得热门节目外，我经历了一切发生在我身上的事情。
I got fired from my first one, the second one got canceled after six episodes.
我的第一部被解雇了，第二部在六集后被取消。
The third one just didn't get picked up by the network, but I thought if anyone's going to go, I think it's going to be this one.
第三个没有被网络收录，但我想如果有人要去的话，我想那就是这个了。
I had that real strong feeling.
我有那种真正强烈的感觉。
We have a question here from our co-producer, Doug's wife, Tally.
我们的联合制片人、道格的妻子塔莉向我们提出了一个问题。
great friend of the show.
节目的好朋友。
Tally does work blue.
Tally 确实可以蓝色工作。
Tally said, what the fuck did they shoot all the future Ted scenes with the kids before they shot the rest of the show?
塔莉说，他们到底是怎么在拍摄剩下的节目之前拍摄泰德与孩子们的所有场景的？
Greg?
格雷格？
Well, we didn't shoot it all before, but we definitely got ahead of it.
好吧，我们之前没有全部拍摄过，但我们绝对领先了。
And season two is when we kind of grabbed all the future-looking stuff that pertained to the very ending.
在第二季中，我们抓住了与结局相关的所有面向未来的东西。
And We grabbed other stuff that we thought could slide in here or there like thing just reactions and we tried to it was kind of funny we just tried to imagine some reactions and we had some ideas that we thought would apply to future future episode ideas but mostly we shot that ending piece with them right because they were going to if the show was in one years it was there were going to be too old and that's what happened and so we just grabbed it was it looking back of his real like Babe Ruth call your shot ball or move to be like clear the set.
我们抓住了其他我们认为可以在这里或那里滑入的东西，比如反应，我们试图这有点有趣，我们只是试图想象一些反应，我们有一些我们认为适用于未来未来剧集想法的想法，但大多数情况下，我们用他们正确地拍摄了结局部分，因为他们打算，如果节目在一年内，那儿就会太老了，这就是发生的事情，所以我们抓住了它，它回顾了他的真实情况，就像贝比·鲁斯（Babe Ruth）打电话给你的投球或移动一样清除设置。
We need these two child actors, and they're going to sign non-disclosure forms, which they did.
我们需要这两个儿童演员，他们将签署保密表格，他们也这么做了。
And we had one cameraman, we had one sound person, who also signed those forms, and everybody else in the set, that's usually a pretty crowded place.
我们有一名摄影师，我们有一名音响人员，他也签署了这些表格，还有片场中的其他人，这通常是一个非常拥挤的地方。
We cleared them out.
我们把他们清理掉了。
I think we did it at the beginning of a day or an end of a day, and we just, nobody else, me and Carter, Pam, Susie, those two actors, David and Lindsay, the kids.
我想我们是在一天开始或一天结束时做的，我们只是，没有其他人，我和卡特，帕姆，苏西，那两个演员，大卫和林赛，孩子们。
And that was it.
就是这样。
And so we just thought we have to do this and if we, you know, however many years pass, we'll always have shot this.
所以我们只是认为我们必须这样做，如果我们，你知道，无论过去多少年，我们总是会拍摄这个。
We'll never regret having grabbed it.
我们永远不会后悔抓住它。
There's no way to grab it eight, nine years from now.
八、九年后就没有办法抓住它了。
So we're going to get it now.
所以我们现在就去获取它。
So we just, yeah, it was, it was an example of using the format of the show to really think forward and think about the future.
所以我们只是，是的，这是一个利用节目形式真正思考未来的例子。
The show is about the future.
该剧讲述的是未来。
And so I think our brains were just in that mode.
所以我认为我们的大脑就处于这种模式。
And so we said, let's do it.
所以我们说，让我们开始吧。
Let's Let's grab it.
让我们抓住它吧。
We had the idea.
我们有这个想法。
Let's grab it.
让我们抓住它。
We have a lot of questions about the order in which scenes were shot.
我们对场景的拍摄顺序有很多疑问。
And I feel like at another time, what might be good to go through just for for fans who don't really know the way TV is put together is kind of let's talk about how the show is happens from Monday through Friday.
我觉得在另一个时候，对于那些不太了解电视节目制作方式的粉丝来说，让我们谈谈周一到周五的节目是如何发生的可能是件好事。
So I feel like let's put a pin in that so people see the that Josh, do you remember after champagne moment after the show is edited?
所以我觉得让我们把它钉在上面，这样人们就可以看到乔希，你还记得节目剪辑后的香槟时刻吗？
Do you remember just watching the pilot for the first time and what your reaction was Craig same question do you afterwards yeah I can't remember the the first time I saw it I can't remember if I got a link I think that Pam maybe invited us as a cast to watch it do you remember Craig do you remember showing I was gonna say I don't know if you got a link you might have got a fucking VHS tape oh yeah I don't know I don't remember but I remember yeah and then I ended up watching it a bunch of times with with an audience because we you know watched it with the the audience to get the laughter.
你还记得第一次看试播集吗，克雷格你的反应是什么，你后来也问同样的问题是的，我不记得我第一次看它的时候，我不记得我是否有一个链接，我想帕姆可能邀请我们作为演员观看它，你还记得克雷格吗，你记得放映吗，我会说我不知道你是否有一个链接，你可能有一个他妈的VHS录像带哦，是的，我不知道我不记得了，但我记得是的，然后我最后看了它很多次与观众一起观看，因为我们知道与观众一起观看是为了获得笑声。
I think, you know, I saw it a bunch.
我想，你知道，我看过很多次。
I've seen the pilot probably more than any other episode.
我看过试播集的次数可能比其他任何一集都多。
Yeah.
是的。
And Greg, you obviously saw it all through the editing process.
格雷格，显然你在整个编辑过程中都看到了这一切。
It's different for me because we edited the hell out of it.
这对我来说是不同的，因为我们对其进行了彻底的编辑。
You know, it wasn't like eight minutes up.
你知道，这还不到八分钟。
You know, it was like, it was supposed to be 22 minutes.
你知道，本来应该是 22 分钟。
It was 31 or whatever it was.
那是 31 或其他什么。
And we had to, we spent weeks whittling it and editing down.
我们不得不这样做，我们花了几周的时间对其进行削减和编辑。
At the weirdest part was watching a focus group test audience watch it with their dials of like, like, and don't like.
最奇怪的部分是观察焦点小组测试观众用喜欢、喜欢和不喜欢的表盘观看它。
And these dials that are all averaged together of this room for the people watching it in real time, you see the lines going up and down of male approval or disapproval and female approval or disapproval.
对于实时观看的人来说，这个房间里的这些表盘都是平均的，你会看到男性认可或不认可以及女性认可或不认可的上下线条。
I think one's blue and one's pink in a stereotypical fashion.
我认为一个是蓝色的，一个是粉红色的，这是一种典型的时尚。
And it's like, ooh, women like that moment, men did not.
就像，哦，女人喜欢那一刻，男人不喜欢。
And people, it's just so weird.
而人们，这真是太奇怪了。
So I watched the pilot every way you could possibly watch the pilot and it was super weird, some of them.
所以我以各种可能的方式观看了试播集，其中一些非常奇怪。
But then when we had it locked or almost locked and showed it to a live audience and recorded their laughs and their responses, which was what aired in the show.
但当我们把它锁定或几乎锁定并向现场观众展示并记录他们的笑声和反应时，这就是节目中播出的内容。
For that one, that was fantastic because people, you knew it worked.
对于那个人来说，这太棒了，因为人们知道它有效。
You knew it worked.
你知道它有效。
I knew it worked before that because everybody that came into the edit room and watched it, every moment that had to work worked.
我知道它在那之前是有效的，因为每个进入编辑室观看它的人，每一个必须工作的时刻都有效。
So I felt confident, but the best moment was finally getting to show a two-in- audience full of humans and not assessing it in any way they were watching it and reacting naturally.
所以我感到很有信心，但最好的时刻是终于向两个观众展示了人类，并且不以任何方式评估它，他们正在观看它并做出自然的反应。
How much Craig at the time, and this might have changed over the course, the show became more successful and you more confident in this new crazy job that you had.
克雷格当时有多少，这可能会在整个过程中发生变化，节目变得更加成功，你对你的这份新的疯狂工作更有信心。
How much of these other voices, whether it's audience reaction or test audience reaction or executives, how much is actually influencing your writing of the show?
这些其他声音中有多少，无论是观众的反应还是测试观众的反应或高管的反应，在多大程度上实际上影响了你对节目的写作？
Yeah, I mean, I think a good note is a good note.
是的，我的意思是，我认为好笔记就是好笔记。
I think we had some very smart executives from both the studio and the network who were really believed in the show and supported it.
我认为我们有一些来自工作室和网络的非常聪明的高管，他们真正相信这部剧并支持它。
it.
它。
And it took some time, sometimes for people for them to get on board, but sort of have serialized the show was and sort of emotional and stuff like that.
花了一些时间，有时人们才加入进来，但有点连载了这部剧，有点情绪化之类的。
But for the most part, they just want to spend for the show.
但大多数情况下，他们只是想为节目花钱。
And it was actually very helpful because we didn't shoot it in front of a live studio audience.
这实际上非常有帮助，因为我们没有在现场演播室观众面前拍摄。
So those responses meant something.
所以这些回应是有意义的。
If we got notes about confusion or boredom or something was slow and just it came from that human like, And executive is saying to me, I felt confused here, or this felt really rushed to me.
如果我们收到关于困惑、无聊或某些事情很慢的记录，而这些记录来自于那个人，那么主管会对我说，我在这里感到困惑，或者这感觉真的很匆忙。
That's good.
那挺好的。
That's really useful.
这真的很有用。
That's a human reaction.
这是人类的反应。
They felt that in their gut and they told us.
他们本能地感觉到了这一点，并告诉了我们。
The other thing that was really useful, and I think Carter pointed this out in his episode, the crew reacted when we'd perform these scenes, the actors would perform these scenes.
另一件非常有用的事情，我认为卡特在他的剧集中指出了这一点，当我们表演这些场景时，工作人员做出了反应，演员们也会表演这些场景。
And the crew wouldn't have read every line of every script or like the new rewrite or whatever that came out the night before we shot.
工作人员不会阅读每个剧本的每一行，或者喜欢新的重写或我们拍摄前一天晚上出现的任何内容。
And they'd react honestly to stuff.
他们会对事物做出诚实的反应。
They'd really laugh.
他们真的会笑。
That's the only way.
这是唯一的办法。
And go cricket silence.
并保持板球沉默。
And then it was only that first time.
然后这只是第一次。
So you had to aggregate responses.
所以你必须汇总回复。
You're getting some responses from different places.
您会从不同的地方收到一些回复。
And you aggregate them.
然后你将它们聚合起来。
And especially if you see link ups, and you're like, oh, that didn't work in three different settings now.
尤其是当您看到链接时，您会想，哦，这在三种不同的设置中不起作用。
It didn't work at the table read, the crew didn't laugh, et cetera, et cetera.
它在餐桌上不起作用，工作人员没有笑，等等。
And you sort of had to take the hit and go, okay, let's take this as a sign.
你必须接受打击然后走，好吧，让我们以此为标志。
We may need to change it.
我们可能需要改变它。
Some stuff you got to believe in, even if it doesn't play on its feet in front of the crew, you say, this is a quiet moment we can, well, this will work in the other room.
有些东西你必须相信，即使它在工作人员面前不起作用，你说，这是一个安静的时刻，我们可以，好吧，这将在另一个房间发挥作用。
There's a different kind of moment.
有一个不同的时刻。
So it's a case by case.
所以这是具体情况而定。
And Josh, I assume you're basically at this point insulated from the larger, louder voices about the show should be more of this, the stuff that Craig and Carter are hearing.
乔什，我想你现在基本上已经与有关该节目的更大、更响亮的声音隔绝了，应该更多的是克雷格和卡特听到的东西。
you in your process early on, can you talk a little bit about what is affecting you?
您很早就处于这个过程中，您能谈谈影响您的因素吗？
Because unlike a play where you're working on this one character and you know it's got to be contained within this two hours, you do have it in somewhere in your head of like the choices that I'm making for this character could live for years, could live as it turns out for a decade.
因为与在戏剧中你正在处理这个角色并且你知道它必须包含在这两个小时内不同，你确实在你的头脑中的某个地方有它，就像我为这个角色所做的选择可能会持续数年，可能会持续十年。
What's happening as you're developing that early on, obviously with the scripts that you're being handed?
当您在早期开发时，显然是使用您收到的脚本，发生了什么？
Yeah, I mean, I think any sort of notes from the Studio Network, I was super insulated from that on the pilot at the very least.
是的，我的意思是，我认为来自 Studio Network 的任何类型的注释，我至少在试播集上与这些注释完全隔离。
Then you end up getting to know the Studio Network executives, and they're there every week, and you become really friendly with them.
然后你最终会认识 Studio Network 的高管，他们每周都会在那里，你会和他们变得非常友好。
They never felt like the enemy was walking on to stage, you know.
你知道，他们从来没有感觉到敌人走上舞台。
But I was very interested in process and in writing.
但我对过程和写作非常感兴趣。
So I remember, I was probably alone, well, among the cast members, and Craig can tell me if I'm wrong, I was probably the most curious about process.
所以我记得，我可能是独自一人，嗯，在演员中，克雷格可以告诉我，如果我错了，我可能是对过程最好奇的。
I was probably the one who asked the most about what was coming up and what you guys were working on and what you were struggling with.
我可能是问得最多的人，关于即将发生的事情、你们正在做什么以及你们正在努力解决什么问题。
And like, I was just, I had an endless appetite for those kinds of questions.
就像，我只是，我对这类问题有着无尽的兴趣。
Some of it was like a little bit like, what's coming down the pike?
其中一些有点像，接下来会发生什么？
Like I wanted to, you know, you become a fan of the show too.
就像我想的那样，你知道，你也成为了这个节目的粉丝。
I was like, I want to know what happens to this guy that I'm playing.
我当时想，我想知道我扮演的这个人发生了什么。
But you know, I still was a relative newcomer to the world of filmed entertainment.
但你知道，对于电影娱乐世界来说，我仍然是一个相对较新的人。
I had done it so much theater since I was 15 and theater, the mercy of theater and somewhat of the sadness of theater is it's a femoral.
从我15岁起，我就演了很多戏剧，戏剧的仁慈和戏剧的悲伤之处就在于它是股骨。
It goes away.
它消失了。
You do it and then you have to keep doing it.
你做了它，然后你必须继续这样做。
It's much more like a restaurant where you have to keep making the food every night, you know?
它更像是一家餐馆，你必须每晚不断地做饭，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And you don't have to be haunted by the bad night's performance or even get to celebrate that much the good night's for.
而且您不必为糟糕的夜晚表现所困扰，甚至不必庆祝美好的夜晚。
It's just it, it evanesc is that the word it just goes away.
就是这样，它消失了，它这个词就消失了。
Right.
正确的。
And with filmed entertainment, uh, I, I found it took me years to, um, become less self conscious and to not think about the kind of like museum quality of it that it would, it would last forever.
对于电影娱乐，呃，我，我发现我花了很多年的时间，嗯，变得不那么自我意识，并且不去思考它会永远持续下去的那种像博物馆的品质。
And I always, always, always wanted another take if one was available because I just wanted another whack at the thing.
如果有的话，我总是、总是、总是想要再拍一次，因为我只是想再拍一次。
But, um, it wasn't until I directed my own movies.
但是，嗯，直到我导演了自己的电影。
And I was in both the movies I directed where I had to edit myself.
我在自己导演的两部电影中都必须亲自剪辑。
And I learned so much.
我学到了很多。
I learned.
我学会了。
It was weird.
很奇怪。
It's something happened to me where I was like, I know what I look like now.
我身上发生了一些事情，我知道我现在是什么样子。
You know when you're a kid and you hear your voice on tape for the first time and you're like, horrified, you're like, that can't be what I sound like, right?
你知道，当你还是个孩子的时候，你第一次在磁带上听到自己的声音，你会感到震惊，你会想，这不可能是我听起来的样子，对吧？
You go through that a little bit when you see yourself on camera, like Craig and Carter as the fireman or the EMT guys, but you still haunts me.
当你在镜头前看到自己时，你会经历一点，就像克雷格和卡特扮演的消防员或急救人员一样，但你仍然困扰着我。
There was this feeling once I edited myself, I was like, I didn't think I looked particularly good or bad.
有一次我自己编辑的时候就有这样的感觉，我觉得我看起来不是特别好或者特别坏。
I just knew what I looked like and I had a kind of ruthless acceptance of it.
我只知道我的样子，并且我无情地接受它。
And since I've done that, I have a much easier time watching myself on screen.
自从我这样做了，我就可以更轻松地在屏幕上观看自己。
It still pops up where you're like, I don't know or I wish they would have chosen a different take or something.
它仍然会出现在你喜欢的地方，我不知道或者我希望他们会选择不同的方式或其他什么。
And it's hard.
这很难。
It's hard.
I think that people don't understand how much self-consciousness is induced by acting on screen.
我认为人们不明白银幕上的表演会引发多少自我意识。
And when I see people, you know, like Lizzy Olson, who was in my first, in my second movie, Liberal Arts, like, she was just, she's just two of the men are born.
当我看到人们时，你知道，就像莉兹·奥尔森（Lizzy Olson），她在我的第一部电影和第二部电影《人文艺术》中，就像，她只是，她只是两个出生的男人。
I think Kobe was like this too, like they're just comfortable being photographed and, you know, fussed over in a way that I, coming from the theater and I don't know, just my general kind of level of self-consciousness back in those days, I had a harder time relaxing.
我想科比也是这样，就像他们很舒服地被拍照一样，你知道，以一种我从剧院出来的方式大惊小怪，我不知道，只是我当时的一般自我意识水平，我很难放松。
I feel like I know how to act in front of the camera in a totally different way than I did 20 years ago.
我觉得我知道如何在镜头前表现得与 20 年前完全不同。
All right.
好的。
We have two questions representing many who asked the same.
我们有两个问题代表许多提出同样问题的人。
Let's do it.
我们开始做吧。
PJ Chandra 612 says, what was the inspiration behind a blue French horn?
PJ Chandra 612 说，蓝色圆号背后的灵感是什么？
I mean, I think that came from, I remember us wanting to, by the way, it's right over Josh's shoulder right there.
我的意思是，我认为这是来自，我记得我们想要，顺便说一句，它就在乔什的肩膀上。
It's the next question on camera here and our little, if anyone's YouTubeing us, it's fantastic.
这是摄像机上的下一个问题，如果有人在 YouTube 上播放我们，那就太棒了。
It makes me very happy.
这让我非常高兴。
Josh, there's a lovely fire.
乔什，有一堆可爱的火。
I can't tell if you have the fire today.
我不知道今天是否着火了。
You do?
你做？
It's a lovely fire.
这是一场可爱的火灾。
It's a winter.
这是一个冬天。
There's the blue punch on it.
上面有蓝色的打孔器。
It's very appealing.
这非常吸引人。
It came from the idea that Carter and I were, we knew we wanted Ted to have to bring something in this sort of very elemental storytelling way, like you've got to, he's got to bring the heroine, a gift to gain entry into her layer.
它来自卡特和我的想法，我们知道我们希望泰德必须以这种非常基本的讲故事方式带来一些东西，就像你必须做的那样，他必须带来女主角，一份进入她的层的礼物。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
There was just this sort of almost like Greek mythological, like he must, he must get a gift and that will gain him access into her world.
就像希腊神话一样，他必须得到一份礼物，这将使他能够进入她的世界。
A boon, yeah, it really was.
一个福音，是的，确实如此。
It feels very like Joseph Campbell, mythology, kind of like just like, let's, let's boil it down to the hero needs to do this to sort of earn his way.
这感觉很像约瑟夫·坎贝尔（Joseph Campbell），神话，有点像，让我们，让我们把它归结为英雄需要这样做才能获得自己的方式。
And then it was like, let's think of something memorable like a hang on a wall.
然后就好像，让我们想想一些令人难忘的东西，比如挂在墙上。
And I was like, we got to that.
我当时想，我们做到了。
You also get the feeling Ted was not into thieving that much.
你还会感觉到泰德不太喜欢偷窃。
Like he doesn't seem like he was a guy who stole a lot of things off a wall from restaurants.
他看起来不像是一个从餐馆的墙上偷了很多东西的人。
I was, is this a, I had these moments a lot, but I'm like, we should have talked about that.
我是这样的，我经历过很多这样的时刻，但我想，我们应该讨论一下。
Like Ted, do you ever stolen anything before?
像特德一样，您以前偷过东西吗？
That could have been a whole episode.
这可能是一整集。
Like, the whole gang stole something.
就像整个团伙偷了东西一样。
Damn it.
该死的。
But yeah, that, that would have been a new thing for Ted.
但是，是的，这对特德来说是一个新事物。
I believe in my heart.
我相信我的心。
That was, that was his first theft, I think.
我认为那是他第一次盗窃。
And he, the idea that he had to run in and do, And sort of like going back to Josh's earlier comment about sort of humiliating yourself in order to sort of move forward in the game, he had to run and jump on to a couple's dinner table, put his knee in like the entrees and grab this thing off the wall, or this couple is sort of a humiliating and sane thing to do, but it got him to the next level of the the rom-com video game to go meet the boss.
而他，他必须跑进去做的想法，有点像回到乔什之前的评论，为了在游戏中前进，他必须羞辱自己，他必须跑跳到一对情侣的餐桌上，像主菜一样把膝盖伸进去，然后从墙上抓起这个东西，或者这对情侣是一件令人羞辱和理智的事情，但这让他达到了浪漫喜剧视频游戏的下一个级别，去见了老板。
I do remember shooting that and enjoying it.
我确实记得拍摄并享受它。
It was so quick.
太快了。
It was fun.
很有趣。
doing your own stunt.
做你自己的特技。
Like it was a little like there was some athleticism to it, you know, it was really fun.
就像有点像有一些运动天赋，你知道，这真的很有趣。
I was surprised rewatching it.
我重看时很惊讶。
I was like, oh, he really had to climb up on a table.
我当时想，哦，他真的必须爬到桌子上。
There was really me climbing up on that table.
真的是我爬上了那张桌子。
I was actually all his own stunts there.
我其实都是他自己的绝技。
Well, Yvonne Vasku, sorry, Yvonne does ask, did any of you keep the blue French horn?
好吧，伊冯·瓦斯库，抱歉，伊冯确实问过，你们中有人保留过蓝色圆号吗？
And remember, this is audio, this is an audio format, Josh, so please talk to us through this over my my right shoulder.
请记住，这是音频，这是音频格式，乔什，所以请通过我的右肩与我们交谈。
We were just kind of asked by the props department and by Carter and Craig like if you could take one thing and I asked for the Blue French horn and I don't, I didn't, I mean, it was so associated with Ted, I don't think there was a lot of competition for, for, you know, I don't think Carter on bartender is like, give me that.
道具部门、卡特和克雷格问我们是否可以拿一件东西，我要了蓝色圆号，但我没有，我没有，我的意思是，它与特德有如此多的联系，我不认为有很多竞争，因为，你知道，我不认为卡特在调酒师上的表现就像，给我那个。
Yeah.
是的。
So yeah, so I asked for the horn and it's traveled with me.
是的，所以我要了号角，它就跟我一起旅行了。
I'm now in, I now live in Albuquerque, New Mexico.
我现在住在新墨西哥州阿尔伯克基。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's been with me for a number of years.
但它已经伴随我很多年了。
Yeah.
是的。
It makes me so happy every time we do this podcast to see it over Josh's right shoulder.
每次我们做这个播客，从乔什的右肩上看到它时，我都感到非常高兴。
It makes me every time I sort of forget that it's there and then it's there and it's like it's delightful.
每当我有点忘记它的存在时，它就让我感觉它就在那里，感觉很令人愉快。
So by the way, you just mentioned the bartender.
顺便说一句，你刚才提到了调酒师。
Do you guys know Joe, right?
你们认识乔吗？
Do you guys know his story of how he wound up on nine seasons of the show.
你们知道他如何结束九季节目的故事吗？
Do you know how it started?
你知道它是怎么开始的吗？
Well, I mean, I do because I was there.
嗯，我的意思是，我这么做是因为我在那里。
Do you mean we're there?
你的意思是我们在那里？
Can he tell the story?
他能讲这个故事吗？
He was, he was going to be a cop that appeared, that appeared in a whole sequence that got axled on the show.
他是，他将成为一名出现在节目中的整个序列中的警察。
I think we cut it.
我认为我们削减了它。
I'm not sure we even, I think we didn't even, did we shoot it?
我不确定我们甚至，我想我们甚至没有，我们开枪了吗？
God, we didn't shoot it.
天啊，我们没有拍到它。
He showed up.
他出现了。
We can't.
我们不能。
He showed up.
他出现了。
He, he, right.
他，他，对了。
I think production forgot to call him and tell him it's cut.
我想制作组忘了给他打电话并告诉他影片已被剪掉。
Yes.
是的。
That was right.
没错。
And he got in his costume.
他穿上了戏服。
Someone put a costume on him of a cop.
有人给他穿上了警察的服装。
He showed up and that's an, that's a question that will haunt me.
他出现了，这是一个困扰我的问题。
Did Wardrobe know it was cut but was like, let's put him in the cop out there.
衣柜知道它被剪掉了吗，但他想，让我们把他放进警察那里吧。
We don't want to be the one to tell him.
我们不想成为告诉他的人。
That's now that I don't know that question.
现在我不知道这个问题了。
So wait, he shows up to set in a cop outfit and you say, sorry, this has been cut.
所以等等，他穿着警察服装出现在片场，你说，对不起，这已经被剪掉了。
No, you can get behind the bar and be the bartender.
不，你可以到吧台后面当调酒师。
That was that's it.
就是这样。
Yeah, that was it.
是的，就是这样。
We felt it because we were still casting the bartender role and we liked him and we had to cast him and then cut this thing at the last minute about a cop.
我们之所以有这种感觉，是因为我们还在选调酒师的角色，而且我们喜欢他，所以我们不得不选他，然后在最后一刻剪掉这个关于警察的故事。
It was like a cop that was going to come on there more than they were all sitting out on the taxi cab outside of Robin's apartment.
就像一个警察会过来，比他们都坐在罗宾公寓外面的出租车上还要多。
There was a whole little bit with a cop and I don't even ask me if I've ever been on what it is because I'm kind of blanking on what it really was.
有一个警察的整个过程，我什至没有问我是否曾经了解过它是什么，因为我对它到底是什么感到茫然。
We cut it and we felt so bad that the message never got to him somehow and that we said, you were great.
我们剪掉了它，我们感到非常难过，以至于这个信息不知何故从未传达给他，我们说，你很棒。
Let's make you Carl the bartender and then he appeared for nine years on the show.
让我们让你扮演调酒师卡尔，然后他在节目中出现了九年。
Unbelievable.
难以置信。
Shout out to Joe.
向乔大声喊叫。
Joe was awesome.
乔太棒了。
He was always so much fun to have on set.
他在片场总是那么有趣。
He was so chill.
他好冷淡。
Yeah.
是的。
in the pilot, he has that, you have that moment.
在飞行员中，他有那个时刻，你也有那个时刻。
He glairs at me because he has mean as his girlfriend.
他对我怒目而视，因为他作为他的女朋友很卑鄙。
I forgot that moment too.
我也忘记了那一刻。
I forgot that.
我忘记了。
I forgot that she was Carl's girlfriend for a second.
我有一瞬间忘记了她是卡尔的女朋友。
I was like one of those little, I mostly had that verbatim that pilot in my brain, but it's like, right, Carl, he, she's dating Carl and he has a good, intimidating look at Ted.
我就像那些小孩子中的一员，我脑子里大部分都是逐字逐句地飞行员，但这就像，对吧，卡尔，他，她正在和卡尔约会，而他对特德的态度很好，令人生畏。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Carl.
卡尔.
It's the most noticing there.
这是那里最引人注目的。
Carl ever got.
卡尔曾经得到过。
Yeah.
是的。
Great.
伟大的。
He was good.
他很好。
He had a presence.
他有存在感。
He was great.
他很棒。
Go, Joe.
走吧，乔。
And I'm sorry about the cop thing, Joe, but I guess it worked out way.
我对警察的事感到抱歉，乔，但我想事情已经解决了。
We have so many questions and so little time.
我们的问题太多，时间却太少。
Craig, you and I have bonded over for all of our many, many decades together, but it is Douglas asked what books, TV shows or stories in general help guide how to tell the first episode.
克雷格，你和我在一起几十年了，但道格拉斯问的是，哪些书籍、电视节目或故事一般可以帮助指导如何讲述第一集。
I guess, bigger question, what are your biggest writing, comedy influences?
我想，更大的问题是，你最大的写作、喜剧影响是什么？
I mean, Carter would have a certain set of answers that would be very important to this too.
我的意思是，卡特会有一套对此也非常重要的答案。
I won't attempt to speak for him, but so many of our answers were overlaps.
我不会试图代表他说话，但我们的许多答案都是重叠的。
This is one.
这是一个。
Cheers.
干杯。
I think we wanted to do a show that had a bar in it.
我想我们想做一个有酒吧的节目。
You wanted to hang out with these people at the bar, and we wanted the bar to be super inviting and warm and amazing, and we just took that from cheers.
你想在酒吧和这些人一起出去玩，我们希望酒吧非常吸引人、温暖、令人惊叹，我们只是从欢呼声中得到了这一点。
But we also love Quentin Tarantino, and we love slicing and dicing narratives and storytelling and finding these nonlinear crazy ways to tell stories.
但我们也喜欢昆汀·塔伦蒂诺，我们喜欢对叙事和讲故事进行切片和切块，并找到这些非线性的疯狂方式来讲述故事。
So it's a Quentin Tarantino plus cheers equals how much your mother with someone Harry Metzeli thrown in.
所以，昆汀·塔伦蒂诺（Quentin Tarantino）加上欢呼声等于你母亲和哈利·梅泽利（Harry Metzeli）投入的数量。
I think you guys told me on the pilot that you had pitched Ted as Lloyd Dobbler from say anything meets George Bailey from its wonderful life.
我想你们在试播集里告诉我，你们之所以选择泰德饰演劳埃德·多布勒，是因为你们所说的一切都与乔治·贝利的精彩生活相吻合。
Were those the two comps that you gave?
那是你给的两个比较吗？
Absolutely.
绝对地。
Big time.
很开心。
And with a special emphasis on George Bailey, I think.
我认为，特别强调乔治·贝利。
Because think about the planning aspect, I'm going to plan my future.
因为考虑到规划方面，我要规划我的未来。
This is what the future is going to be.
这就是未来。
I've got it all mapped out.
我已经把一切都安排好了。
I mean, in some ways beef should, it's an actionable rip-off.
我的意思是，从某些方面来说，牛肉应该是一种可操作的敲诈勒索。
We really, we really took a lot from it.
我们真的，我们真的从中受益匪浅。
Some Georgia Valley main character of its wonderful life for you, kids playing along in the home game.
乔治亚谷的一些主角为您带来了精彩的生活，孩子们在家里玩游戏。
He's this big dreamer who thinks he's going to plan everything out and life proves otherwise and life also proves that there's a richness to be found when it doesn't all go according to plan.
他是一个伟大的梦想家，他认为自己会把一切都计划好，但生活证明并非如此，生活也证明，当一切不按计划进行时，可以发现丰富的东西。
I'd say that was a big spiritual forebearer of Ted, but Lloyd Dobler, big time.
我想说这是泰德的一位伟大的精神先驱，但劳埃德·多布勒是伟大的。
I mean, so much so with Lloyd Dobler that when you walked in the door and like had a little Qzaki inequality to you, Josh, it's red first.
我的意思是，劳埃德·多布勒（Lloyd Dobler）是如此之多，以至于当你走进门时，乔什（Josh）对你有一点Qzaki不平等，它首先是红色的。
So you're not to say like you seemed like John Geary your own man, but it definitely helped like there was kind of like a wit and an intelligence and your eyes had felt like a young John Qzaki.
所以你并不是说你看起来像约翰·吉尔里（John Geary）自己的人，但这绝对有帮助，因为你有一种机智和智慧，而且你的眼睛感觉就像年轻的约翰·卡扎基（John Qzaki）。
Oh no.
哦不。
At that time, my life is someone called me.
那时，我的生命就是有人叫我的。
That's a compliment.
这是一种恭维。
And I would, I would take it as a big compliment.
我会，我会认为这是一个很大的赞美。
You don't miss it.
你不会错过它。
Okay.
好的。
Yeah.
是的。
Mentos is a big compliment.
曼妥思是一个很大的赞美。
My last question on paper here is from Chris.ram asks, will you be filming this podcast?
我在纸上的最后一个问题是 Chris.ram 提出的，你会拍摄这个播客吗？
So here we are.
所以我们到了。
They're very excited.
他们非常兴奋。
If you are listening to this right now, just know that this is also on YouTube.
如果您现在正在听这个节目，请知道 YouTube 上也有这个节目。
You can check it out.
你可以检查一下。
There's so many questions about this pilot.
关于这个飞行员有很多问题。
There's 300 more here on Instagram and everywhere.
Instagram 上和其他地方还有 300 多个。
Is there anything left?
还有东西吗？
What else should we talk about about the pilot?
关于飞行员我们还应该谈论什么？
Because we're moving on to episode two.
因为我们要继续看第二集。
I would just say that one thing that struck me watching the pilot was the sense memory of the challenge of having to have Robin meet the rest of the gang.
我只想说，观看试播集时令我印象深刻的一件事是让罗宾与其他团伙见面的挑战的感觉记忆。
Robin, Kobe Smolder's, only has scenes with Josh in the pilot.
科比·斯莫尔德的《罗宾》在试播集中只有乔什的场景。
never interacts with anybody else.
从不与其他人互动。
And I remember that feeling at the end of the pilot, like, we better have a good episode, too, that shows how she kind of works her way into this group and be friends with this group because that's a whole other sale we have to make of, like, she's the fifth banana.
我记得试播集结束时的感觉，就像，我们最好也有一个好的剧集，这表明她如何进入这个群体并与这个群体成为朋友，因为这是我们必须做的另一件事，就像，她是第五根香蕉。
She's, you know, she's the, she's the fifth part of this five-part puzzle.
她是，你知道，她是，她是这个由五部分组成的谜题的第五部分。
And we had to sort of integrate her and show how everybody else kind of fell in love with her, too.
我们必须将她融入其中，并展示其他人是如何爱上她的。
And I, I had that feeling in my body.
而我，我的身体里也有这种感觉。
It's sort of re-experienced that, like, we got to somehow thread the needle on out.
这是一种重新经历，就像我们必须以某种方式把针穿出来一样。
We got to make the sale.
我们必须完成销售。
Like, I remember feeling that way When we had to write episode two and three and that we're sort of like showing her becoming part of that group and yeah It was just fun.
就像，我记得当我们必须写第二集和第三集时，我们有点像展示她成为该团体的一部分，是的，这很有趣。
Remember that challenge and we'll rewatch and talk about if we if we did it I think we did I think we pulled it off.
记住这个挑战，我们将重新观看并讨论我们是否做到了，我认为我们做到了，我认为我们成功了。
I have two things one is if you watch the pilot of how I met your mother the DNA for the entire show is in the pilot Yeah, like absolutely the entire kind of structure and essence and and surprise switcheroo kind of thing that they did so well, it's all, it's in there.
我有两件事，一是如果你看《我如何遇见你母亲》的试播集，整个节目的DNA都在试播集里，是的，就像他们做得很好的整个结构和本质，以及令人惊讶的切换之类的事情，就这样，它就在那里。
It's like the raggoo sauce or whatever.
就像拉古酱什么的。
It's like it's in there.
就好像它就在那里一样。
What people understand that, you can cut that if they don't.
人们理解的内容，如果他们不理解，你可以删掉它。
The other thing I wanted to say, this is just a funny thing that my wife said this morning.
我想说的另一件事是，这只是我妻子今天早上说的一件有趣的事情。
She was like, she knew someone who had, who lived on the upper west side and he had a dog named Teddy and everyone called him the dog Teddy West side.
她就像，她认识一个住在上西区的人，他有一只名叫泰迪的狗，每个人都称他为泰迪西区的狗。
And I love, as one of Ted's, he had so many nicknames, Teddy West sides a great nickname, I thought, but it was also self-proclaimed, right?
我喜欢，作为泰德的一员，他有很多绰号，泰迪·韦斯特有一个很棒的绰号，我想，但这也是自称的，对吧？
He called himself Teddy West side.
他称自己为泰迪·西边。
Yeah, I think he was trying to get everyone else on board.
是的，我认为他试图让其他人都加入进来。
They weren't on board.
他们不在船上。
Yeah, but she said, so where'd they live?
是的，但她说，那么他们住在哪里？
And I said, they lives on the upper west side, right?
我说，他们住在上西区，对吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And she said, but Robin lives in Brooklyn.
她说，但罗宾住在布鲁克林。
And I said, yeah, she said, because Robin's cool, because we, like, Jordan, she grew up in Manhattan, but she lives in Brooklyn and she just can't stand going into Manhattan.
我说，是的，她说，因为罗宾很酷，因为我们，就像乔丹一样，她在曼哈顿长大，但她住在布鲁克林，她就是无法忍受进入曼哈顿。
She loves Brooklyn.
她爱布鲁克林。
But she said, how was she hanging out on this bar on the upper west side so much if she lived in Brooklyn?
但她说，如果她住在布鲁克林，怎么会这么频繁地在上西区的这个酒吧里闲逛呢？
Yeah.
是的。
She was terrible.
她太可怕了。
Here's what I, here's what I rationalized.
这就是我的，这就是我合理化的。
I think her TV station is close by.
我想她的电视台就在附近。
Yeah.
是的。
Let's say that TV is in mid, TV stations in Midtown somewhere.
假设电视在中部，电视台在市中心的某个地方。
So she's like, why not?
所以她想，为什么不呢？
Or even in like the West 60s, like where the West 60s, like that sort of like CBS building, like West 50s, 60s, that whole thing.
或者甚至在像西 60 年代，像西 60 年代，像那种像 CBS 大楼，像西 50 年代、60 年代，整个事情。
So then she just pops up a couple of like 10 or 15 blocks and hangs out with her friend.
于是她就突然出现在 10 或 15 个街区之外，和她的朋友一起出去玩。
But also, she's out so late and she has to get up at like 3.30 in the morning to do the early.
而且，她出门这么晚，必须在凌晨 3.30 左右起床才能早起。
Just a day, like an hour and a half.
就一天，一个半小时左右。
These are the kind of threads we'll be pulling, that'll be.
这些就是我们将要拉动的线索。
Yeah, at some point she moves, but it's true.
是的，在某些时候她会移动，但这是事实。
For a while she had a real shit commute.
有一段时间，她的通勤经历真是糟糕透顶。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
Olsen's off again.
奥尔森又下课了
New York City.
纽约市。
how we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Artwork by John Marrow.
约翰·马罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）创作的《NYC》。
special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳德。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemajormother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on substack.
在 substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的时事通讯。
Read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com.
阅读 Craig Thomas 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文。
And you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的 Dead Father Society。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
The real question, it just hit me Am I in love with you or just New York's?
真正的问题，我突然想到我是爱你还是只爱纽约？